did you see some of the other images
that were out with these guys on bumper
cars and they took over an amusement
park and they were having fun I mean
they're trying to humanize themselves
and I agree people are you know
vulnerable to this messaging without a
doubt and the point I made earlier too
is once mainstream media starts buying
into it which they probably already are
you know then there's another way
they're going to be subjected to it and
you mentioned kids I mean kids are
getting bombarded every single Direction
they go College you know from professors
Hollywood the in in elementary school
right now here's the next thing that
they're going to do to kids they're
going to segregate them on whether
they're wearing have been vaccinated yet
and the fdea hasn't approved the vaccine
and you're talking about by the way
Culver City in La just uh is the first
school district in LA that is mandating
that 12 and above have to be vaccinated
to go to school all right okay Culver
City School District I still work in
coverage yes right by Sonia yes
so you got to get vaccinated if you're
12 and up yep to go to school this year
they just came out with it yesterday
yesterday or Tuesday I know know and
it'll fall like dominoes in the rest of
La I guarantee here's what I'm trying to
like what's the formula
people come to America for options and
choices how do you lead with Force you
know for years we took flu shots and we
took vaccines it was a choice yeah you
took it this is when you do Force it's
it's not a marketing strategy that's
effective
plus those vaccines were FDA approved I
think you get a lot of people that are
just a little bit afraid of the fact
that it's not FDA approved although it
could happen I heard by the end of
August but yeah that's what kids are
dealing with right well look to go back
and that's that's a whole other ball of
wax man that the the segregation that
they're doing right now and the
stratifying of society between the
obedient and disobedient is something
that's that's really really Troublesome
but look I I have to admit and I and
maybe maybe the reason that that I feel
the way that I feel about this is
because after 9 11 happened you gotta
you know I grew up in the shadow of the
towers uh I I I I I
became there's no other way to say it
like in islamophobic I really did I for
a long time for years after I was one of
these dudes that was like not screw
Muslims they're all the same they're
this and that like they they destroyed
these people and uh dude I was wrong I
was young you know and I was I was flat
out wrong so when it comes to this you
know I have to wonder man like so much
of what's going on in Afghanistan is the
fault of our government George Bush Dick
Cheney Donald Rumsfeld the entire you
know establishment regime for whatever
reason whether it was oil whether it was
access whether it was poppy whatever
reason we were there to we we weren't
there for for the right reasons and we
we destroyed the entire generation man
and you know this is our across the Bear
in some ways and I'm not I look I'm not
pro-taliban I got to say that as loud as
I can again but I also don't want to
fall into that same category of We're
the good guys they're the bad guys we're
we're on the side of righteousness
they're on the side you know what we
have to have some enemies right because
right now I mean we do have legit
enemies but no one is hearing about that
and if you're a kid the messaging you're
hearing and if you're a vulnerable
person is the only enemy is someone that
doesn't believe in you in what you
believe politically or maybe socially
that that is the only enemy and that is
the only message these people hear we
don't talk about threats to this country
and the legit enemies that we have I I
am way more worried about the fox and
the hen house than I am about to tell a
man 6 000 miles from me I have to be
honest I am way way way more concerned
about ivy league professors than I am
about Taliban right now I am way way
more concerned about media Executives
inside my own country than I am about
the television you're worried about
shaping of the mindset I am you're more
worried about that Kami Professor then
you're worried about the television no
doubt about it no doubt about it so you
are the Shah you're thinking like the
shot you're worried about a mindset
spreading is what you're worried about I
I am worried about things that I think
that we can control so here's a question
for you I got a question for you okay
historically do you know how the
Communist membership has done have you
ever studied how to combination in the
United States have you looked at the
numbers yeah what have you noticed what
have you found uh that when times are
bad membership goes up when times are
good membership goes down fraud out and
by the way how bad is a drop off when
times are good yeah so it's almost to
the point where they have to make times
bad of course of course to recruit but
when the times are great what happens to
their membership they fall away they
fall away how bad is it by five percent
or like 80 yeah everybody grows up
essentially everybody grows up 80 okay
let me ask you a question
percentage-wise go from 1930 1940 when
did Karl Marx start really creating
momentum what you what you're well
19th century but yeah I would say the
Bolshevik Revolution okay end of world
war one so let's just go from there
let's go 20s yeah okay let's go 20s 30s
to today okay go 20 2030 still today
percentage-wise percentage-wise of
Communism membership in U.S is it the
same today as it was 90 years ago
it's an interesting question
percentage-wise yeah okay I'm not
talking number I'm asking persons yeah
it's an interesting question it's
probably lower okay but I think it has
way more people in the mainstream
sympathetic to the idea sympathetic is
different but there are a lot of
sympathetic people you know moms are
sympathetic too but you know it's okay
you know you should forgive them it's
okay it's okay to be sympathetic but the
membership has declined is that a fair
thing I wouldn't expect that I mean
listen ussrs or it's rebranded the
actual Communist Party China is now got
an element of capitalism in it it's the
government that's communism that wants
to control the narrative but the
business you can go out there and make
money in China yeah it's futile but yeah
yeah okay so so all I'm saying to you is
the idea of Communism has gradually lost
momentum is that fair percentage yes
okay so now let me flip the question on
you here's a question for you
go from 40 years ago 1981.
to today
1981 to today Taliban Hezbollah
extremist any of those not not Muslim
the religion that's the biggest I'm not
talking to religion yeah I'm not talking
about the people that you deal with who
are Muslim who are peaceful loving
caring they're just like how you
something how are you a Muslim yeah I'm
a Muslim I follow some of the stuff that
Prophet Muhammad talked about
but has the Taliban Hezbollah Isis have
they increased on the last 40 years yes
percentage-wise absolutely is it by
small percentages by a big percentage
well it's it's by a big percentage and a
lot of that's our doing so what I'm what
I'm saying I I don't disagree but their
number one enemy in the world is America
because everything America stands for
they don't stand for everything America
stands for they don't stand for they
want to do whatever they can for
everybody who represents the westernized
mindset to be taken off of the face of
the Earth anything to do to get rid of
them point I'm trying to make to you is
the one you're worried about sometimes
is proven that it doesn't work they're
just a bunch of people that are going
around you know crying whining well it's
not fair let me tell you that these
capitalists all they want to do is put
people to work and it's like slavery and
this this this the ultimate slavery is
communism let's face it that's the
ultimate slavery
but the one you have to worry about is
guys like this so for me when they're
okay with them creating this kind of
momentum just look at the percentage of
growth the last 40 years it validates
what we have to really be careful with
they flat out hate you right they don't
not like you they hate you they want you
dead they they wish you were not here
it's a very different mindset so if you
enjoy this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]